WILLIAM VANBENEPE:
In this session,
I'm going to describe
how Cloud is especially
useful and convenient
for Big Data processing.
I'm going to show how to
use Big Data the Cloud way.
Some of you may think
Big Data is out of reach.
I'll show you why
it's not the case.
Some of you are probably
already using it.
I'm going to show you how
you can get a lot more done
for a lot less work.
I'm William Vanbenepe.
I'm a product manager in
Google Cloud Platform.
When you think about
Big Data, these
are some of the things
that come to mind.
Obviously there's a
lot more than that.
But these are the concepts
and tools that come to mind.
But if you think about it, none
of those are about Big Data.
None of those are about what
you're trying to get done.
Those are constraints
of the tools.
Those are limitations.
Those are things
you have to learn,
things you have to deal with.
So today, when thinking about
how to run Big Data the Cloud
way, I'm going to ask
you to forget about this.
If you don't know about then,
don't assume you have to know
and master them to use
Big Data efficiently.
If you already know about
them, take a mental holiday.
Or take a real
holiday-- even better.
But at least a mental holiday.
Clear your mind.
You don't have to
actually forget all of it,
but don't assume that these are
the starting points for any Big
Data project.
Instead, focus on
your application.
Focus on what you're
trying to get done.
And focusing on your
application really
means focusing on the people.
So let's pick an example.
Let's say that you're
building a multi-player mobile
application, a game, where
player interact in real life,
where they also
interact in the game.
And that's the application.
That's what we're
trying to get done.
Who are the people who matter?
Obviously, first and
foremost, your users,
on the upper left, people trying
to just want to use the game
and have a good experience,
have interesting things
happen to them.
And then you have developers,
in charge of building the game.
And because this is a game with
a lot of player interaction,
part of what they
have to do is make
sure those interactions happen
in a way that's meaningful
and engaging.
Of course, on the
flip side you don't
want negative interaction.
So you also have
to watch for abuse
and make sure you
police the game.
You also have people who
have more of a data science
angle, who want to analyze
user engagement models,
try to understand what motivates
users to come back to the game,
and what happens if they lose
too many challenges, if they
win too easily, if
they meet friends,
if they don't meet friends.
How does that impact
their tendency
to come back to the game?
And obviously, you have
people with business concerns,
trying to understand,
how am I doing?
How am I growing?
Am I investing in the
right marketing channel
to bring the right users?
Are my users staying with me?
And just understanding
what the revenue streams
are and things like that.
So those are the
people who matter.
And these are the things
they're trying to do.
None of those people say, I
want to work with Big Data.
What they say is, I
want to do those things.
So let's show how using
Big Data the Cloud
way we can make it really
easy for those things
to happen for these people.
Starting with this events--
users playing on the game.
Things happen.
Events, either
[INAUDIBLE] are emitted.
First thing to do is
capture the events.
And for that we're
introducing today
a new Cloud service
called Cloud Pub/Sub.
Cloud Pub/Sub is a reliable
many-to-many asynchronous
message delivery system.
So just by the
name, Cloud Pub/Sub,
I assume some of you in the
room already know what it does.
It's a well-known
architectural pattern.
It's widely used
in some domains.
It's very convenient from an
architectural perspective.
It makes your architecture
easy, simple, and also easy
to evolve.
And yet it's not used as
broadly as you would think,
because it also comes at a cost.
It comes at a cost of
relying on an infrastructure
to manage that
stream of messages.
And that can become a
single point of failure.
bottleneck in your application.
So for that reason, that
very convenient pattern
is not as widely
used as it could.
Today with Cloud Pub/Sub
we are taking the burden
of running and managing
the system for you.
So you can benefit from the
simplicity of the pattern
without paying the cost
and the risk of having
to manage the infrastructure.
Cloud Pub/Sub is a global
service delivered and managed
by Google.
When you start using
it we don't ask you,
do want to be located on the
Easy Coast, on the West Coast?
It's one single
Global Entry point,
supported by Google's
global infrastructure.
It scales to just what you need.
So if you saw the keynote this
morning about Cloud data flow,
because we had so little
time in the keynote,
we didn't describe
the [INAUDIBLE].
But actually that demo had
Cloud Sub/Pub in the front,
ingesting the tweets
that were being analyzed,
that's the demo
about the World Cup.
Something like
the World Cup, you
can imagine when
the goal happened
you had a spike in
traffic that goes down.
We're not talking
a two-month spike.
We're talking like
a two-minute spike.
So these are the kind of
things that normally you
would have to provision for.
Or you would just
be running behind.
And when you don't need it
you would be overpaying.
Cloud Pub/Sub scales
to just what you need.
You don't have to manage it.
And you pay just what you need.
And that's Big
Data the Cloud way.
So looking through a bit
more detail about how you use
Cloud Pub/Sub, at the
heart of if are topics.
Topics are what you define,
what you care about.
You say, I'm going to
create a new topic, topic
of first-class resources.
So they have access
control lists.
So you can give permission
to users in an application
to post to a topic, and
give permission to others
to subscribe to the
topic and read from it.
Obviously I'm not
breaking some trade secret
by saying that there are
computers under the cover, many
of them powering that.
But they're not your concerns.
What you worry about
are topic and messages.
Cloud Pub/Sub is durable.
So if your subscribers are
available at the time when
the message comes through,
it gets immediately delivered
to them.
If they're not, the
messages are safely
persisted until they come up
and all the subscribers have
consumed and acknowledged
the messages.
Scalable, reliable
with no management.
That's the Cloud way.
It's not just that the
system itself is resilient,
it's that it makes
the architecture
resilient and
resilient to change.
So in our example, in the
early days of the company
the only thing that
matters is having
a game that can be played.
There is no time for analytics
or any other niceties.
And yet you know that there is
value in those early events,
in those early logs
that are coming out.
So what you can do is just
create a Pub/Sub topic.
Have all your application
clients just post events there.
And have a very simple consumer
just to write to storage,
and leave it there.
And you can forget about it, and
you're safely storing the data.
And then as you mature,
as you need evolve,
as you have a bit
more breathing room,
time comes for you
to do something
useful with those events.
And at that point, you
can create an application
which is going to register to
the topic and consume events.
And by doing that you're
not changing anything else.
It's a very safe move.
You're not breaking anything.
You're not modifying anything.
On the left side you don't
have to change anything
to your publishers.
You don't have to update the
application and deal with half
your users having the
new version, half of them
having the old version.
Or even worse, in
some cases you're
publishing from sensors
or devices embedded
in the field, which are
almost impossible to update.
No update on the left side.
You're not disrupting anything.
You're just adding one consumer.
And as time goes, as you evolve,
it's a very flexible pattern.
So you can add more consumers,
many consumers to one topic.
You can even chain consumers.
So for example, you
could have one consumer,
which is trusted to see the raw
data coming from the players.
And it removes
confidential information.
It enriches, cleans,
filters, any preprocessing.
And it can republish
to a second topic.
And then that second
topic can be the one
that you open up to your
larger set of users,
for them to run analytics
or other development tasks.
As you evolve over time,
as your needs evolve,
it's a very powerful
architectural pattern.
And now we give you the tool
that lets you use it safely.
So we've been talking
about applications
without saying much
about what they are.
What are those applications
that consume events
from Cloud Pub/Sub?
Well, they can be
anything, really.
It can be an application
on Google Compute Engine.
Could be an application
on Google App Engine.
It could be an application
on this laptop.
It could be in your data center.
It's a very open and
versatile service
you can consume from anywhere.
Today, for the purpose
of this session,
we're going to focus on one
special case, one special kind
of consumers, which is
data processing pipeline.
Because remember,
what we really want
is to allow developers to
focus on the application,
not on the infrastructure.
And in our example, many of the
use cases, what they call for
is a data processing pipeline.
So looking on the upper right,
managing user interactions,
so making sure that users
who are in the same team,
in the same location, who
have similar objectives,
can find one another
and play together.
Detecting abuse, making
sure people aren't harassing
one another, analyzing
user engagement,
all those things
are best expressed
as data processing pipeline.
And that's why we're introducing
today another service, which
you saw in the keynote this
morning, Google Cloud Dataflow.
Google Cloud Dataflow
is the right tool
for data processing pipeline.
It lets you write your
processing pipeline
as one simple Java program.
The initial version is Java.
The service itself is
actually language agnostic.
But the first SDK is a Java one.
And then you let us,
you let Google deal
with everything that's needed
to run that processing pipeline,
with all deployment, monitoring,
tuning, configuration tasks.
As [INAUDIBLE]
mentioned this morning,
this has replaced
[? My Produce ?] at Google.
It's actually third generation.
There's a complex family tree
of data processing products
at Google.
This is replacing
the service which
replaced [? My Produce ?]
at Google.
So this is something that,
even though it's a new Cloud
service, it's a very
mature data processing
tool that we've been
using internally.
So let's find out a bit
more about what it does.
This is your application in
many cases, like in our example,
a constant stream of events
happening to the system,
in our case, going
through Cloud [INAUDIBLE].
In many cases, this
is the shape in which
you want to consume them.
You want to handle them in
real time as they come through.
Because remember, we're
talking about user interaction.
It's not very useful if I get a
notification at 4:00 AM telling
me, last afternoon you
and two team members
were in the same location.
You could have mounted
an operation together,
or something like that.
It's too late.
Same thing with abuse.
If you find people who are
harrassing others, or people--
somebody reverse
engineered your client,
and they're playing
programmatically in the game
and creating havoc.
If you find them 24
hours later, they've
had hours to make
other miserable.
And those users are
not coming back.
So in those cases, you want to
analyze on the fly, right away,
and take action right away.
And that's why Cloud
data flow supports
running in streaming mode.
In that mode we
let you tell us how
you want events
grouped and aggregated.
We make that happen for you.
We call them buckets.
We let you tell us if you want
things bucketized by session ID
for web traffic, by time
window, either fixed
window or sliding window,
in the case of the game,
probably by team, by location.
You tell us how you
want events aggregated.
We make sure that those
buckets are created for you,
that your application logic
is processed on the content.
And as new events come in and
as all the events age out,
we take care of keeping
the processing always fresh
and up to date.
There are other
cases where you want
to run against
historical data, so
taking the example of
user engagement models.
When trying to understand
how user behave and react
to things happening
in the game, you
want to benefit
from weeks, months,
years of historical information,
where you've seen the impact.
And so for that,
Cloud Dataflow lets
you run your pipeline
in batch mode
and go against all
this historical data.
And the interesting thing
is that it's actually
the same program which
is running in batch mode
and in streaming mode.
The changes are very minute.
There are some changes
to how some of the IU
operates, to switch from reading
files or tables to reading
streams, voice input and output.
And then you've
configuring your bucket.
Other than that, the actual
algorithm that you're running
is the exact same in both cases.
And that's very powerful.
That means that, in the case
of the user engagement model,
once you have created your
model about how users react,
you can take the same mobile
and run it in stream mode
so you can see in real time
as you adjust parameters
of the game, or
as new users come.
You may have a
marketing campaign
that brings a new kind of users.
As those things
change, you can see
how your user behavior
compares to what you expect.
And you can make
adjustments on the fly.
Another use case
for which we'd want
to run the same pipeline
in by batch and stream
is the case where
you make changes
to your pricing algorithm.
So you've been pricing events
as they occur, and then
you realize you
have a bug or you
have an idea for a new feature,
just additional insight
that you're trying to extract.
At that point, you can
change your pipeline,
and all the new events
will get processed
with the new algorithm.
But the old ones aren't
comparable anymore.
What you'd like to
do is reprocess them.
And that's where running the
same pipeline in stream mode
and in batch mode
is very useful,
because you get to reprocess
as much of your historical data
as you want.
And of course, because
you're in the Cloud,
you have capacity
available to do that.
You don't have to worry
about taking capacity away
from supporting
new events in order
to manage the reprocessing.
You just get what you need.
That is Big Data the Cloud way.
So I mentioned, and
[? Ors ?] said earlier,
this product is based on
10 years of parallel data
processing research at Google.
And when I say research, I
mean in a very applied way.
Pretty much all the Google
product you use every day
are based on these technologies.
So even though it's
a new Cloud product,
there's a lot of
maturity internally.
And that maturity
doesn't just show up
in the capabilities in the
APIs that we expose to you.
A lot of it is under the cover.
It's in our ability to take
your pricing pipeline, which
is expressed in a very
simple, intuitive way,
and turn that into a
processing pipeline, which
is very efficient to execute.
And then, as we execute the
pipeline on your behalf,
we take care of all the
work that you shouldn't
have to worry about--
starting machines, starting
the right number of machines,
monitoring, tuning, babysitting
in cases where some workers
have a problem restarting work.
All that is done for you,
buyers, in an optimized way.
There's a session in this same
room tomorrow at 10:00 AM which
is dedicated entirely
to Cloud Dataflow.
Shows you a lot more detail.
We'll show you
some code as well.
So please come
back here at 10:00
AM and you'll find out a
lot more about how it works.
One of the things with those
highly optimized systems
is that it's really hard
to know what's going on.
So if everything goes
well, you're happy.
As soon as you're trying to
understand what's happening,
either because
there's a problem,
there's a bug in your code
or there's a bottleneck
that you're trying to
eliminate by writing
your code differently,
then you're
left with the task of assembling
all the logs, to finding them
and trying to make
sense of them.
Even once you've found all
the logs and brought them,
they're expressed,
in many cases,
in terms of the
optimized execution
plan, which makes
no sense to you.
That's not a code you wrote.
So for Cloud Dataflow we've
made sure not only to collect
all the relevant logs and matrix
for you when we present them,
but to do that in a way that
matches directly to the way
you have defined your pipeline.
So every step,
every task described
here corresponds to some
line of code in your code
that you recognize.
It's understandable
and it's actionable.
So these are the
two new products
that we are introducing
today, Cloud Pub/Sub
in limited preview, and
Cloud Dataflow, currently
in private beta.
What about this green cylinder?
It represents all the
Cloud storage services
at Google, of which
there are many.
Today I'm going to focus
specifically on one of them,
BigQuery.
That's the one that's the most
relevant for large scale data
analytics.
So unlike Cloud
Dataflow and Pub/Sub,
BigQuery is not a new service.
It's been out for
a couple of years.
Some of you I'm
sure know about it.
Some of you use it.
You may not be aware of the
latest improvement, though.
For those who are not
familiar with BigQuery,
it's a large-scale SQL
based analytics engine.
You bring your data.
And then you send
queries that we
execute on the data
you've brought.
So once again, it's a
fully managed service.
You're not responsible for
deploying, tuning, managing
a cluster.
The storage is handled
separately from the processing.
So if you store data
and do not query it,
that's perfectly fine.
You don't have to pay for an
unused cluster which is just
sitting around to store data.
You only pay for
storage at the same rate
as Google Cloud Storage.
When you want to
process, you have
an engine at your
disposal, which
is capable of processing
terrabytes of data in seconds
and gives you an
interactive experience
for real time analytics.
That flexibility in the model
between storage and consumption
becomes very clear in cases
such as public data sets.
So some of you may have
heard, just last week,
that some data was released
from New York City around all
the taxi cab rides in 2013,
I think a bit under 200
million taxi cab rides,
and pretty detailed data
including starting point,
ending point, price, tip,
time of the day.
That was released, and somebody
just put it in BigQuery
as a public data set.
If that happened
anywhere else and you
wanted to use that,
you would have to say,
well, thank you for the data.
Let me set up a cluster.
Let me import your data.
And then I can work.
And by that point I've
paid already a couple hours
of cluster [? pricing ?] time.
With BigQuery all
you have to do is
go to the web console,
enter a SQL query,
and in seconds you
get your results.
And you can find
out that December
is the month where tips
are the highest in average.
Maybe not very surprising.
In seconds you're in business.
And you're only paying for
that query or the query
that you decide to run.
And by the way, the
first terabyte of queries
is free every month.
Going to more detail
into BigQuery,
especially for those of you
who have used the product
but may not have seen all
the recent announcement,
it supports a very rich and
flexible ingestion model.
So there is trimming ingestion.
That's what Dataflow uses.
When Dataflow processes events
and puts them into BigQuery,
it happens at a streaming API.
Obviously you can load
files in batch mode.
If you use Googly
Analytics premium,
we have an integration where
we can take your unsampled user
clicks data from Google
Analytics premium
and put that for you
directly in BigQuery.
So that data is available
for you to analyze any way
you want.
You can bring additional
data and join it
with CRM data, marketing data,
third party demographic data,
whatever you want.
The data is yours, easily
accessible in BigQuery.
We've also partnered with
many other companies who
provide additional
sources of information,
like social network information,
and also companies who provide
tools like ETL tools to simplify
bringing data into BigQuery.
So that's on the ingestion side.
On the consumption side, it's
also a very flexible service
with many ways to consume data.
For example, you
can consume data
from Cloud Dataflow,
as we saw earlier
or from Hadoop, which
we'll discuss later.
And to support that,
BigQuery allows
data to be made
available in parallel
to many workers
at the same time.
There's also a simple
table read API.
If you use Python, you can
use the pandas library,
for example.
There's ODBC support.
But obviously out of all of
those, the most popular way
to use data in BigQuery
is via the BigQuery engine
itself, that powerful SQL
engine I described earlier.
And it's not just SQL.
In addition to
that, the engine has
a lot of additional support for
more modern data pricing tasks,
or more Big Data kind of tasks.
So for example, it
supports nested records.
It lets you query
inside JSONObject.
If you have JSONObject
stored in the database
you can query inside of
them during the query.
It supports view.
It supports regular expressions.
And coming soon we will
have support for user
defined functions in JavaScript.
So here's our business user.
In addition to
BigQuery, which gives
him or her interactive
access using
the dashboard to a large amount
of historical information,
either a dashboard that
they did themselves
or a dashboard from
our many partners,
like Tableau and
Click and [INAUDIBLE]
and others who've created
commercial dashboard
with great visualization
[INAUDIBLE] Big Query.
In addition to that interactive
view of historical information,
thanks to Dataflow
working in streaming mode,
the business user can
also get a real time view
of how things are
going right now.
So which are my top five
most popular games right now?
What's my rate of
new users joining
the game of what's
my attrition rate?
All those can be
calculated in real time
and also presented
for a full real time
and historical business view.
And obviously BigQuery is not
just for business analytics.
That's just one example.
It can also be
used by developers.
Today a lot of developers
use [? hive, ?]
for example for data processing
of structure data in SQL.
BigQuery can be used
as a development tool
to do just that, except much
faster and without any overhead
or management complexity.
And that's Big
Data the Cloud way.
So I mentioned other storage
services on Cloud platform.
I'm not going to go into
details of any of them.
But they're Google Cloud Storage
for object store, Cloud data
store, our managed NoSQL, and
Cloud SQL, a managed MySQL
solution.
They're not specific to
analytics use cases, obviously.
But they are well
integrated in the platform
and can play a role there too.
Let's say your
developer has decided
she wants to use
Pig to ingest data.
I have some ETL pipeline for
which that's the right tool.
Or maybe your data
scientist wants
to run mission learning
algorithm using
a library for Spark.
Or he or she wants to
do real time scalar
analytics using Spark.
Those are the right
tools for the job.
Those are available on
Google Cloud Platform.
And those can be made to
run the Cloud way as well.
So what does it mean to
run opensource software
like Hadoop and
Spark the Cloud way?
Well first thing, Hadoop runs
great on Google Cloud Platform.
Because of the quality and
the consistency of the VMs,
of the network,
and of the storage
it runs really efficiently
on the platform.
And you can have a
traditional deployment.
And when it comes to
HDFS you have a choice.
There are three different
[? blog ?] storage services
appropriate for HDFS.
You can use the
traditional persistent disk
backed by spinning disk.
You can use the SSD-backed
persistent disk,
which just went generally
available today.
Or you can use the newly
announced local SSD, which
was announced today and is now
available in Trusted Tester.
So you have three
different services,
three different performance
characteristics,
and three different price
points available to you
depending on your needs.
But you don't actually
even need to set up HDFS.
We've created three connectors
to Google storage services,
one for Google Cloud
Storage, one for BigQuery,
one for the tester.
These connectors
implement Hadoop native
API such that your code in
Hadoop, your [? map produce, ?]
your Pig, our Hive, if
you use Hadoop streaming
in other languages, or Spark,
because Spark uses the same IU
interfaces as Hadoop, your
user code in Spark or Hadoop
can run entirely unchanged
and access data directly
in Cloud storage in
BigQuery, in Datastore.
That means that the
data is not logged
in silos into one cluster.
You can have several
Hadoop cluster
working as the same data.
And you can also have
BigQuery working [INAUDIBLE].
You can have Cloud Dataflow
working [? against state. ?]
The data is not locked into
a specific pricing engine.
It's available for all.
And so those are available,
all three of them.
The GCS connector's actually
opensource on GitHub.
The other two, we
haven't done that yet.
But the plan is to make
them widely available
in opensource for everybody,
to make it very easy,
architecturally makes
it very easy now.
Because you don't have
to worry about when
you spin your cluster,
coping data into it,
and then making sure that
you set the data back
before you turn it off.
You can use those connectors
in conjunction HDFS.
Or you can use without HDFS.
This is really as you
see fit, as you prefer.
In addition to the
connectors we have also
created a tool called BDUTL,
which stands for Big Data UTL.
That tool automates
the deployment
and the configuration
of Hadoop and Spark
on Google Cloud Platform.
So we'll deploy them.
We'll spin the VM,
as many as you want.
We'll deploy.
We'll configure including
installing and configuring
new connectors.
And the cluster is
available for you to use.
So you should take that
level of automation.
If you add to that
the connectors that
give immediate
access to the data
as soon as the
cluster is up, if you
add the fast boot-up
time of the VMs on Google
[INAUDIBLE] engine and the fact
that you pay by the minute,
all those things
together really give you
a tool set that allows a much
more flexible and dynamic way
to run Hadoop clusters
in Google Cloud Platform.
And that's how you can
run Hadoop and Spark
and other opensource
tools the Cloud way
on Google Cloud Platform.
So as we describe the
services of the platform
and how together they can
help users focus on the task
they're trying to achieve,
not focus on setting up
emerging infrastructure,
as we describe
that we [INAUDIBLE] with
that someone complex picture.
So let's simplify
it a little bit.
At the end, the heart of it
is three fully managed cloud
services which do one thing,
do it really well, and make
you really productive-- Cloud
Pub/Sub for event handling.
Cloud Dataflow for data
processing pipeline,
either in stream mode
or in batch mode.
BigQuery for
large-scale analytics.
And then the ability
to integrate and bring
the best of the
opensource ecosystem
and to have those opensource
tools work in the manner that's
well integrated with
the platform, such
that you don't have to choose
to be in one world or the other.
You can mix and
match as you see fit
and have all those
services work together.
And we see that in practice.
And we have customers who
already have set up Big Data
clusters on premise
or on some IES cloud.
And they can bring that as
is to Google Cloud platform,
to benefit from the
Cloud consumption
model, the quality of
the infrastructure,
the cost, the scalability.
They can bring it
with no modification.
And then as they see
fit, if they want to,
opportunistically
they can decide
to use BigQuery or
Datflow, Pub/Sub
to lowered their emission
burden for the task
where they think
that's the right tool.
And vice versa, going back to
our example of a new company,
at that station in
the life cycle, what
companies value
most is velocity.
The last thing they
want is to spend
time worrying about
infrastructure
and configuration.
And so the fully managed
services are by far
the most productive
way to get started
and to build an entire platform.
And it's not just the
easy tool to get started,
because the scale is there.
These are the tools
that can carry you up
to the larger scale
that you will need.
That being said, they
don't do everything.
They don't try to do everything.
There are tasks for which
Pub/Sub, Dataflow, and BigQuery
are not the right tool.
And for that there is a rich
ecosystem of opensource tools
which we've made sure
can run well integrated
into Google Cloud Platform.
And that's the overall choice
that we want to give you.
And that's how we want
to put you in control
and let you decide how you want
to run Big Data the Cloud way.
More information
coming up in this room.
This is the right place to be.
10:00 AM tomorrow,
the [INAUDIBLE] Data.
This is a session
specifically on Dataflow.
4:00 PM also here tomorrow.
Predicting the Future with
Google Cloud Platform,
which will show you how to
use BigQuery and Dataflow
for a concrete
practical example.
And then we'll have
many developers and PMs
at the sandbox, talking about
those [INAUDIBLE] topics,
as well as on the Cloud
booths on the floor.
So please come and see us there.
And we'd like to
discuss your use cases
and how these tools
would apply to you.
And finally, thank you for
coming here in San Francisco.
Some of you have traveled a lot.
We're coming to you as well.
We will have Cloud
roadshows, hopefully
to a city close to yours.
So please check out this URL and
see when they'll be available
and when we're coming to you.
If you want more information
about Cloud Dataflow
we have set up a
Google group where
you can register to be
informed of new announcement
for the product.
And Cloud Pub/Sub is now
available on the website.
The documentation is there.
It's a limited preview.
So if you're
interested in joining,
there is a form where you
can put your information
and request an invitation
to the limited preview.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]